Okay. So let's get started. This is a
special, we'll talk in particular for me.
Uh, I want to introduce
you to [inaudible]. No, he
gets a very good friend.
I'm going to make the disclaimer
first. Uh, actually it's my, uh,
marriage witness.
So
we known each other for 16 years roughly.
Uh,
I'm not gonna give all the details of
how we met the challenge, so don't worry.
Uh,
we met in Argentina like a on the 31st
of December in a party and we have many
friends in common and then we grew
over time on our friendship and uh,
now I wanted him to share
a little bit with you.
He's a track record what he has done in
business and of course her some advices
and things to you. So like, I
really like to start the first.
I thank you for making the time and uh,
I'm coming here and
joining us on a second.
Do you mind sharing a little bit of a
who you are and what is the company you
created?
Okay. Hello everybody. I'm put
to dry my English that perfect.
So what I will do my best if not the same
French, most of them understand. Okay.
I try. No, I will try in
English. I like challenges. Um,
thank you. You know, to invite me here.
I was supposed to be on holiday with
my family or four way, but you know,
wants to be back to work apparently. So,
uh, so now I'm very happy to be here. Uh,
very interesting for me to visit the
Google a few years to see a tight works
here and uh, and uh, I'm very, very happy.
So roughly I,
I'm I creating with a friend of
a company called line in 1999.
So it's a quite a long time ago.
Um, you are very, very young.
I was very young. No, it
was uh, not my first job.
I had worked for two years before
in a very, in a company called ICI,
chemical inputs, chemicals industry.
So nothing in common with, uh,
um, technology. But at that
moment, I don't know, it's,
it was the beginning of Internet.
Everybody was setting up companies,
so it was really getting bored in this
big company. And I was thinking, uh,
I should, uh, I should dive into
this, uh, this new movement.
So first, I, uh,
I joined a startup who has cupping a
Ebay more or less in France and I'm on,
it was solo rapidly to a, to
another company. So I decided to,
to create as the line. So we had an
idea, I had an idea. It was that, uh,
every day,
lots of new websites were created in
France on most of them couldn't make money
basically. Um, they were, oh, they
were all dreaming of making money,
but they were too small. They had to,
the audience was too small to, to,
to make money basically. So
we thought, okay, if we could,
if we could all this
audience, uh, together,
if we make a big audience and we
could sell the advertising space,
it was a very simple idea.
And at that time, a good,
good at sense was
naturally here. Um, so, um,
w somebody, yeah, yeah. Was
good to here as well. And yeah,
it was maybe in the US,
but in France,
essence was not what was not here at
that time. So we first started, uh, uh,
to, uh, develop the technology
to a kind of a nutshell.
And that's a serving
technology, um, that could, uh,
uh, that make it easy for
webmaster to, to, to describe.
And, um, I bought a, uh,
so advertising pages in Geek
magazines with a very simple message.
It was a webmaster,
subscribe at the line and make money.
And we had a notch of success with this
very simple, uh, advertising campaign,
hundreds of websites every week where
subscribing because they had basically no
solution to make money.
Uh, and that was here 2000,
19 to 2000, I would say. And, um,
so we were ready to, we have the stock
of, of advertising space to sell.
So we started to sell it to advertising
agency basically on the strategy was to
sell a low price. So, um, we, uh,
created, um, a micro billing
solution to enable this website,
some of these websites to, to put a
pay wall basically on the, on the,
on the pages. And it was a,
it was a very easy way to, uh,
to, uh, create this
pair work. Just a very,
very,
very easy way.
So as money in advertising disappeared
table was the solution you came up,
but it was a macro. So it was uh, um,
basically you had to, to, to,
to dial a premium, a phone,
a phone call, you get a tick a code
on a, you enter the code on the page,
you get the content. So it helped us
to go through this two years, 2001,
2002, uh, what the market was very,
very difficult.
And in 2003 when the market started again,
we had no more competitor
on the advertising part.
They were all there basically in France.
And um,
it was at that moment,
it was a very special moment because
of the markets started to be really a
bullish. And, uh, we had a
very, very strong growth and uh,
in some area we didn't even,
we didn't have enough space to sell,
so we thought, okay, we don't
have enough space cells,
so we're going to create this
space. So we started, uh, uh,
creating space and creating
websites basically. And big,
we became a publishers in some rough,
the first website was a zone Odessa,
it was a comparitor a price
comparison site. Yeah.
Comparison site for Isp,
because we had lots of advertising
advertisers at that time who were fighting
for market share is up
in France. And then, uh,
because we had a very
strong growth, we, uh,
I met someone who proposed me to make
an IPU, basically because we had,
I met a guy and say, oh, you should make
an apo, or really, how does it work?
I had no idea. Basically and a while,
you always have experts everywhere.
So he explained me how it works and it
takes people who know how it works. And,
uh,
one year after we raised 15
million euro to an IPO and,
uh, basically it was to, um,
accelerate the movement towards publishing
because at that moment a Google was a
really ready with
essence. And, uh, so the,
the last 2007, 2008, no,
it was 2006, six. And,
um, our strategy, which was a to go, uh,
to use the long tail of
basically of website, uh,
to, uh, to get back on
the advertising market.
Google was on the cake and we
had to find out quickly and, uh,
uh, a new, a new, a new
business. So I thought being,
um, uh, uh,
being a master of your website was the,
the solution.
So we raised that money and we
invested in websites that were,
that were some of,
of where in our network we have a very,
a strategic vision of which websites
were accelerating more than others.
And, uh, so we invested
maybe a 10, uh, 10 websites.
Sometimes it was a minority stake.
Sometimes it was a majority stake.
Uh, we acquired, uh,
uh, associated account.
I know if you know it in
France, miserable that, uh, uh,
more or less than stellar
10 websites. And, um,
we continue the, um, the development until
2012. And, and, um,
and we sold the company actually
to, to a French, a big group. And,
uh, I'm still, uh, I'm still,
uh, CEO of the company.
Uh, so it's now four, five
years after when I sold it,
I thought I would stay two
years and Leland finally,
I'm still here. I don't know.
I don't know how it comes at. I'm
still here. They still like it. Yeah,
I dunno.
They maybe don't like it. I don't know.
But I'm still here. Uh, it was, uh,
four years ago I was, I got married.
I make three babies at that time.
So, um, I didn't waste my time,
I guess, you know, that come on.
I guess it's not that common that you
find somebody with a track record and the
expertise. So even if, uh, uh, they,
they wanted to find somebody else,
uh,
I'm not sure we'll have the competencies
experience and they inserted well,
it's a very big challenge for big
groups. So that's how I don't have
the, the Internet culture too,
to what the investments in
smaller started like us.
It's very complicated to integrate them.
That's a very big problem.
And I still don't know mia really.
I'm ready to go actually,
but I'm really scared of what, of what
they would do with the company after that.
So,
and now we are,
I'm very attached to compare the
really care you're really a task.
But I think it's a very big challenge
for big groups to integrate because they
have process, big process.
And uh, we are very, uh,
a giant company and uh, it's
very, it's a very big challenge.
But part of, uh, of uh, independence you
let to the, to the, to the company on.
If you don't have the founder who
will take the lead after it's,
it's a bit complicated I
think. Okay. Not always easy.
So let me ask you a couple of things
into the scripture and you read another
line.
Um,
let's talk about the tough moments
because it's 2000, 2001, you know,
the stock market goes down,
there's no funding. Uh,
by the time there was not a lot of believe
into online advertising. Right? Um,
and then, uh, your main source or
only source of revenues goes away. Uh,
and then you can creatively within a
solution that lets you survive. Well,
what are the toughest moments
and what did you learn? Well,
I think the tough moments or first
to creation, when we started to,
we did a business plan, we went to see
a business angels on nobody first, uh,
very few people, uh, even very
bright and smart people. Uh,
the best educated people, but older
generation probably like me now. Uh,
but do you really believe
in this internet? I mean,
we have these type of, of,
of answers.
It was really amazing and I'm so it was,
we tapped because we had
to start it without money.
Then after the second tough one,
you said it was a,
when the bubble exploded and we had no
more money and we have to find solutions.
And basically we were smoking.
We were maybe a 12 or 12 people and
we had to get to sick to shrink to six
people maybe. I guess we
nearly didn't get paid. Uh,
me and my partner, I slept in the
office during more than a year,
so it was really tough. Um, and
when, when the, um, when the,
the markets, I've, when I felt that
the market was, I'm starting again,
uh, because we had two business
Anja, I thought, okay, I want now,
now I'm ready to fight again,
but I don't want to fight for,
because we had lost the majority of the
company that was so I was not ready to
fight to, to suffer again,
uh, for less than a majority.
So I offered the two business owner to
buy the shares for basically the price.
I,
I bought a,
they bought them plus 5% per year and uh,
and accepted. So I sewed my, my
flight, which was my only, uh,
I had a small flat in Mamata I sold it
to but to buy it and plus I borrowed a
bit at the bank. And you became a
homeless. Why your own company? Yes,
exactly.
But that's,
that was the time I slept in
the office secretary and uh,
and uh, but, uh, it was uh,
totally crazy. I would not,
I would never suggest
people to do that crazy.
I don't think your wife will appreciate
it if I post something like that was
crazy. But, uh, at the end of
the day of the date was, uh,
two years later we went to public. So, uh,
of course the value is not
at all the same amount.
You can imagine now a of the share.
But, uh, so it was a, it was crazy,
but uh, it worked actually.
And uh, that's how it went.
We went public and we had 100%
of the capital was my partner,
which is quite rare in our
industry. Most of the, of the,
of the people who go pill down or they
are already diluted by many a vcs on an
business.
Sanchez.
You were just,
you had the vision to trust and you
trust that your business so much that you
bought it again,
your sheriffs.
I, yeah, I think it was crazy. And, and
we were lucky, I think not only lucky,
but also lucky.
And the more I work,
the luckier I get.
I don't know, but I wouldn't
do it today, which, sure. Sure.
Okay. So, um, I think that I
have some inside information,
no,
to complete the tough moment as ways to
sell the company is a very tough moment
as well because you, you sell it on a,
you don't know if he's stupid or not.
Now I'm really happy to have
solid actually, but, uh,
it's a very tough moment
because you have to, you,
you have the impression too that you are
selling you your son or something that
belongs to you. It's very, very
emotional and very hard to,
it's a very hard money if even
if you basically get money. Okay.
So you're happy to get money and so at
least says so what now? And uh, it's very,
very tough moment in
terms of emotion. And, um,
so let's,
let's for a second,
I assume that anyone here
or anyone watching the video
are going to start their
own company. What would be the top
three advices that you will give them?
Uh, to, uh, make sure that they maximize
their chances of being successful?
And I hope it's not sell your apartment,
investing in your own company.
No, no, really? I, it's very hard to
stu to give advices because me media,
lots of people give,
give you very bad advice basically.
No, it's true. A very, very smart
people always told me, okay,
I know your business managers is okay,
but you should wait
two years and packages.
So I think the advice would be
not to listen too much to advices.
No, no. Hello. You are,
um, your faith. If, if you,
if you, you really need to have the
two to 12 the face in something,
in an idea, and you have to
be really willing to do, to,
to create your company.
If you're not ready,
if you just want to create a company
because it's fashionable to create a
company because it's cool, it's, um,
you must be ready to suffer. And if,
if you're, um, if you really have a
vision on faith, on a big whale, you,
you will not feel the, I mean, the bad
moments basically. And, uh, so you're,
you, my, my, my advice is, uh,
you have to follow your,
your idea and to you,
it must be strong. Not, not very smart
but very, very strong in you, in you.
And um,
my,
my advisor as well is you have to take
risks but so the sooner the better I
would say because uh, for example,
me today I have three children,
I will not take the same risk.
It was not appropriate for me to
sleep in my office two years. It was,
I had nothing. I ha ha I had this little
flat. So if you fail, it's not a big deal.
You know, you fail, you, you lose if you,
so the sooner the better I think don't
weight that your product is perfect
before you go. I mean now I invest in, in,
in many companies on I,
that's kind of by some people who wants
to have something perfect before go. No,
you go, you go on, you, you, you
repair on board, you return ball.
So that's,
that's my advice.
My advice it would be to trust for me are
very important too to share experience
with someone.
You must have a dream or a vision and
you have to share it with someone because
it's very bring the tough moment.
If you are alone, it's very so long.
It's a long journey. So it's
very tough to be alone. Me,
I could not have been alone.
So I have a very good friend is he has a,
you can name him if you want.
[inaudible] is a very good fun.
He has a very good temper as well.
So it's,
you have to to,
to share the adventure with someone
that who have the same value as you.
Someone who will not kill you for money
for example. You know, or someone who, um,
who said, okay, this is a battle.
This is not an orange. You know,
because in some situation people
say, no, sorry, it's not a battle.
In a ranch you have to share a vision.
Value is your partner.
And um,
as well for difficult moments,
it's nice to have a partner on as well
to share if you have the best, uh,
best moment, if you are alone. It's
quite sad if you have a, you know,
so it's better to, to, to, to
be, to, to share. And then after,
if you, uh, if you have
a good, a good team,
I would say the hard thing is to get with
people with you on the boat, which is,
uh,
that's a such a beautiful board at the
beginning and you need to have a quality
people on how to get them because you
know that all the best to go to either go
to Google or set up the company. So how
do you do? Wait, we are happy with that.
They're happy.
They come to us a big problem.
So how do you do so you
have to share your dream to,
you have to be very
enthusiastic, yes. To, uh,
to make a nice people come on
board with you. You have to share.
You don't have to be nice to people to
be so that good people join John Your,
I don't show me.
Basically,
I'm going ask you a little bit now on,
on your angel investments and then start
thinking about questions if you want to
make and then I'll give it to you less.
So when you sold the company,
you are still are the CEO
of the company. Uh, but now,
well,
the bank account is a little bit better
and you are expanding your reach. Now.
What is in your mind?
What are you doing?
How would you like to approach a future
investments and things like that?
Well, um, it was a big, it's
a big question. When you
sell your company, you know,
what am I going to do next on it?
So it's a big question on youtube,
too young to retire. Um, you have,
you have not updated your dreams
because when you create your company,
you are new. And when you're
25, I don't know, maybe you,
you dream of going surfing on the beach,
uh, uh, if you had enough money to and to,
to stop working on when you sold your
company, you're nearly 40 and say,
I don't want to go anymore surfing and
a bitch. Nobody's there. And all my,
so what, what, what? I'm too fat anyway,
so it's too late. So you have to update
you. You have not updated your dreams.
So it's very big. It's
kind of a trauma, you know?
So it's very hard to,
very hard to, to, to,
to readapt yourself too.
What am I going to do?
So first I started to invest in companies.
So,
but it's a bit frustrating investing
because you aren't, you you invest on,
it's like a then always Amy
money. No, we were quite lucky.
I mean I have invested in,
one of my first investment was sold to
Google was a company called mage talk.
It was a, uh, um, a visual
software on a,
so to Google.
So we had a good adventures. I had
nothing to have nothing. And uh,
what needs to be, it's frustrating
when you, when you are an entrepreneur,
you want to, you want to lead your own
board basically. Yeah. And you, you,
you don't want to put money in a,
you know,
it's like buying a foot rest and wait
five years or so she's got growth. Uh,
you know, it's not, it's not for
me. It's not in, it's not enough.
So I think I will create something.
Something else. Uh, I'm not,
I'm not sure exactly what,
but um,
I know some of your side business
project. Yes, I have a few
projects, but for sure I will, uh,
I will start again as something
a big or not, but nice.
That's, um, guys, you have any questions?
I hope you understood what I said
because it was a bit confused.
They have a chip is Google translate
so don't worry, they get everything.
You stopped to the,
um,
you call ins.
Others,
how easy talking today,
the main source are.
So Steeler kind of fat cells or how is
no,
I've changed,
we are not anymore on the long tail.
We are now,
we have a big websites in a
contract with big, big websites.
So we have moved the from uh, the, uh,
small websites too big websites basically.
So we have a more traditional,
uh, network, uh, advertising
network business.
It's still a, I would say, uh, nearly
half of the business of the company.
But it's a tough business because now
you knew in France you have to be a quite
big, you have a, we have 25 million
unique users in France and I,
I would say it's the minimum not to
lose money or in, uh, so it's, it's the,
the, the growth is, is quite, uh,
quite low. Uh, we are still on,
um, the micro billing, uh, still a,
it's still a good business, but we
have, uh, adapted it as well to the, um,
because of pay pal now is everywhere
on all the need to call anymore.
We have the, we have adapted it to
put more services with the, with,
with our billing because just the billing.
Now big companies are in this market.
So we,
we tried to put a service layer
of service with a voice basically.
Um, you guys are now on this market
as well. We are everywhere. Um,
but it's still a good
business and I believe in, uh,
in billing services through voice,
um,
and the publishing,
uh,
it's still good and we have a,
we have one website that make
the money from, for the others.
I would say we have a leader, uh, in, um,
facilities or companies is still making
good money. Basically we are selling,
we are selling, uh, uh,
information information on the company's
financial information companies. We buy,
uh,
we buy raw information,
we clean it,
and we sell it in retail
and with Google's Bella, Bella? Yes, yes.
Well, uh, I'm not sure it's very
rational. I would say there's a,
a large part of instinct,
um,
that I feel through the exchange,
the talk with the founders and, um, I, uh,
invest very early stage and
so I would say no money.
The statistic is you invest in
10 companies and uh, when uh,
goes a well on most of the others died.
Basically that's supposed to be a
statistic for us. It's not a statistic.
We are much better than this because I
invest with my partner and we would say
we have no,
we have one company which is in
difficulty out of maybe 15 company,
but most most of them that are in good
shape. And so I would say instant,
uh, of, of the determination
I have in the, um,
the founders, the founders, I would
say it's the first, uh, it's my,
uh, my first, uh, key
and the business itself,
of course the business
you need to be on the market
that is coming. You must,
I don't invest in where there's no market
basically with where it's too soon,
you know, the timing and
the time to market is very
important for us. For example,
we were very lucky because
of the time to market it.
Plus not a strategic was
luck basically, but, uh,
two years before we would have died
two years after it was too late.
So that time to market is
very, very important. And uh,
but basically the profile of the founder
is very important because you have to
adapt all the time. If, if, if,
if you have someone who is not able to do,
is to sure of where he wants to go,
it's not good because you need
people who are very fast, who was,
who are ready to change very fast,
can adapt them a business
model very fast. So, um,
I don't invest in people who are to
show of themselves basically, uh,
because, uh, you need to be
humble. I guess I'm going
to uni started company. So,
um, and I, um, and after it's, uh,
yeah, it's, it's, it's a part
of a instinct of self first.
And of course I know a
bit the market as well.
I invest in intern mainly on
internet businesses, so I know
a lot of the ecosystem, few things, few
things. And I tried to invest not a,
uh, on a singular person, businesses.
And so I liked to have access
to partner three partners. Good.
Uh, like a technical guy, a business
guy, and a design guy for example,
is fantastic. That's the
best, uh, the best, uh,
technology I would say. And, um,
there's no, I don't have like
my five rules for investment.
I don't have this. And,
uh, but, uh, in five years, five years,
I would add alarm. I will have a good
view if I a good investor or not.
For now it's, it's too sooner.
Maybe I would have one we had to,
to come here was sold
already. Good, good. Uh,
no to yes, yes. And uh,
I'm still optimistic and
most of them. And uh, so,
but we will bring him back again in
five years and then he would, yes.
Yes, I would come. Okay.
And do you think the same
today or in the bus?
Okay,
what a good question for me.
I find it more,
it's much harder today than 20 years ago
because 20 years ago there was a big,
big, uh, thing. It was a internet was new.
So this a disruption was so huge.
You don't have,
you don't find this disruption today.
I mean,
so even someone stupid would jump into
the water or no would follow the currents
and we'll do something. I would
say, uh, it's a bit of a joke,
but it's not totally a joke if you
are in the, in the right moment.
Uh, now I find it very difficult. Why?
Because all the smart people going out
of a big university business school,
they,
all three companies,
they all read the same newspaper
or they worked for Luder. No,
but the, the, Oh, they work for good.
It's true. So you have a swimming.
I received maybe a 10
business plan every week.
People who want to raise money
and quality of people is amazing.
The quite the business
plan are fantastic and uh,
it's, it's, it's very hard to find space.
You will have so many brightest bright
people, smart people, Great Company today.
I mean, I'm sure they will. Not
all sepsis for sure. For sure.
So I find it more difficult now than
20 years ago because you have much more
people and you don't have such
a big disruption. Maybe I was,
I was saying to truly know, I
would say I'm a blockchain is, is,
is there interesting. Yeah.
Blockchain for me is, uh,
probably the big disruption to
my, in my opinion, in my opinion,
but the other disruption are
like extension of previous,
uh,
disruptions I would say like mobile or
video and all these big companies are
already there. You know, uh,
you have to go and it's very
nice when you're going to market,
not mature on a bit Celtic where
big companies, big organization,
and it's a,
it's that easy for them to say blockchain
is perfect for this, I would say.
So. What do you think about
the future of club team?
Well, uh, people have had the same
idea with the Internet, you know,
and the people very smart,
educated people told me that
Internet is a burger, you know,
so I hear the same as this blockchain.
So I think, oh, that's probably good.
Something good, you know? And,
uh, I, that's why I want to,
I want to dig in, in this direction. Now.
I think blockchain is something really,
really, uh, I don't understand very
well blockchain, to tell you the truth,
I don't understand
everything and induction,
but I feel that this is something a very,
very deceptive that will change a lot of
things, like a new dimension of, of, uh,
of business.
Interestingly,
I'm successful now whether its
founding a company or selling it or,
or does it not work like that?
No,
I'm not gonna have a problem with the
world of success. I know. So that's why,
you know, success for me is
something really weird. You know, uh,
I don't know if you have read this
in the newspaper. You have a, uh,
Albert Einstein. He just, uh, uh,
wrote and he wrote a note of paperwork
that was sort of million dollar in an
auction or yesterday or the day before.
And it was a,
it was a literal world success
and happiness, you know, and, uh,
he said basically that,
um,
he had found the secret of happiness
that it was not, uh, not, uh,
tried to find a success success at
old price. So success for me, it's,
it's something, uh, so we had, um, world,
I don't really, uh, feel I
had success. And, uh, for me,
success is to achieve your goal and
try to be happy. That's the only, uh,
uh, success you may have in
the life, my opinion. So, uh,
if you are, if you are lucky to make
a business and to put the successful,
maybe develop it so they
make money is nice. But, uh,
so it's kind of a success, but if you,
you have many little success every day.
So I never had this,
the idea of having made
the success on, uh, oh,
it's, uh, for me, um, it was, uh, uh,
an obligation to do, to, to create my
company because I, I, I hate others.
I don't like a Yorkie and disciplines or
not. So I had no choice basically. So.
So, uh, so that's why I created a
company. So it was not a success.
It was the survival a thing, you know, so,
so in a way it was a s I
survived in a way, so, oh well
my idea was that we were lucky, very
lucky. I was saying we are very lucky.
It's just a new lead.
But we were very lucky in all the stories
and I think I'm a very lucky person.
And,
uh,
but luck is of course a being rapid in
grabbing opportunities now for sure. But,
uh, so I, I grabbed a
thesis if I can, of course.
Yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes.
So well where we, Nigga, I
negotiated in the deal to,
to keep my office far from their office,
let's that of the dealer.
And um,
they're respecting that I worry that
they watched this or this is to preserve
the culture. I know it's a big challenge
for, for, for, for companies to,
uh, Lopez for example, they
want to, of course, to, to,
to have a digital culture because they
have a big problem, you know, nobody,
you anymore,
the stamps business,
which is a 20 billion euro turnover in
France is decreasing 10% of the year.
So it's, wow, what do you do?
You have to find solutions.
So when the strategy is to buy
companies, uh, digital companies to,
to prepare the future,
but the answer, the,
how do you do the integrate that there
have not my opinion in my opinion, uh,
answer this question on, uh,
the fact that we're still here.
If that's okay, what are, what's
going to happen when we're,
when we're going to leave?
Because the country is so different
and we fight to keep our culture,
basically we fight to a certain extent.
Basically.
I'm gonna say we fight,
we say we think it's a good
a idea to let us very, very,
uh, far from you. If you
want to keep the, the,
the good people they're going to
leave if you put too much Yaki,
too much processes that
Dumas on [inaudible] on this,
right?
Yes.
But it's a big challenge for them to be
a big challenge because I read something
on it,
but a,
the L'Oreal a CEO today who said
that a digital culture come from the,
the, the ground that from the top.
You can't say, I want my group to be,
have a digital culture now. And you
say, do it now. It doesn't work.
This grows from the ground on. Um, so, um,
big challenge I would say,
but then they're not too
bad. They're not too bad in,
in, in, in doing this.
Any last questions guys?
If not, we're going to do something very
important. We are embarked lake, uh,
to be a mentor for Google as well.
Thank you. Can you call out for the,
for the teachers? Okay.
Next time he comes,
we can mentor a few, a few startup
scene here in the Mena region.
I love Google.
I bought shares
[inaudible].